we're seconds away from season two of  the drew barrymore show we say go big or  go home but we're gonna do both fire  this thing up  because there truly is no place like  home i'm going coast to coast from new  york to california and everywhere in  between to celebrate all our hometowns  so let's do this from the place i was  born and raised hello hollywood this is  the drew barrymore show  [Applause]  hello everybody  hello  hello  welcome  i can't believe we're here  this is all for you guys and it means so  much to all of us because  you  are our very first in-person studio  audience  [Applause]  we didn't have the privilege of that in  year one and what a way to kick things  off we are here in my hometown of  hollywood  at the iconic  paramount studio  my grandfather john barrymore  shot here  i love that hello hello  [Music]